tune in because you never know what's
gonna happen oh
we're tuned in because larsa pippen just
broke her silence after fans noticed
that kim courtney
and khloe kardashian all unfollowed the
former real housewives of miami star on
instagram
and larsa she isn't following the
sisters anymore either
it all started on tuesday night in a
since-deleted tweet
kanye west simply wrote larsa with zero
explanation naturally that got people
talking and on wednesday the 46 year old
mother of four
addressed the headlines in her insta
story writing that she prays
everybody finds peace should we go
instagram live and ask people what they
want to know about
larsa explained quote i woke up this
morning blessed and see that
everybody is focused on who i am
following and who i am not following on
social media
i am focused on my children my new
fitness brand larsa pippen fitness
and my relationship in real life
gotta love that she dropped a little
self-promotion while she had
everybody's attention well done anyway
the reality star wrapped up her post
writing that she hopes others focus on
their own lives and what makes
them happy interesting
now it's not clear what went down
between larsa and the famous fam
but they've all been friends for a long
time
we had a really good time all the girls
are amazing larsa has even popped up on
keeping up with the kardashians
a lot over the years i talk a lot
my fave larsa cameo when she and court
took hip-hop dance lessons and kim was a
total stage mom
i'm like a notorious non-dancer i just
don't dance
okay i make money moves and of course
kim refused to dance
we need to get more into it okay like
the sideline anyway larsa's comments
came just hours after kim spoke out on
her husband's bipolar disorder
following the 43 year old rapper's
recent series of tweets and public
appearances
even if my wife were to divorce me after
this speech
she brought north into the world even
when i didn't want to
she stood up and she protected that
child kim took to her insta story
wednesday
asking for compassion and empathy from
the public
i've seen him go through a lot i always
know his heart
kanye has been posting and deleting a
bunch of tweets over the last few days
including one where he claimed he had
wanted a divorce
and another that alleged kim and her mom
kris jenner were trying to take him to a
hospital
a source told et on wednesday that
behind the scenes
kim is just trying to do what's best for
her family
kim is going through a lot but she's
staying strong for their children
kim wants to help kanye and has extended
numerous avenues to do so
but he's not responding to it and seems
to get more upset
when she or anyone close to her tries to
help
you